Hey folks, thank you for checking out my
DIY time channel and today we're going
to learn how to program Toyota smart
key. Also, if you find this information
somewhat helpful, please show your
support and appreciation by subscribing
to my channel and you will also get
notified whenever I upload new videos on
how to do DIY car repairs and projects
or when I'm giving away some free cool
stuff.
For this project, we're going to need a
Windows-based computer and a special
cable to connect the computer to the
OBD2 port on your car. You can buy this
cable at the link I provided below this
video.
After you install the drivers and
software for the cable, plug it into the
OBD port on your car and into the USB
port on your computer.
Next, remove your foot from the brake
pedal and press the start button twice
without starting the engine. Next,
launch the software that came with the
cable and then connect to your vehicle.
Next, select your car, make, model,
year, engine code, and the smart key
option.
Next, go to smart key menu. Click on
utility button and then click on smart
code registration.
On the next page, you'll need to confirm
that you met all of the requirements
before you can start programming
procedure.
On the next page, you can see the number
of spaces available for new key codes.
As you can see, in my case, there are
only two key codes registered to my
vehicle. So, I have three more spaces
available. If you don't have any spaces
available, just go back to the smart key
menu and erase some of the codes of the
keys that you lost or you don't have
anymore. Before you start, make sure to
put the new key that you're trying to
register at least one foot away from the
vehicle and put your existing registered
key inside the vehicle.
Next, you'll need to click on pre-start
check button to review the registration
process.
Read about all of the steps for
programming procedure and then close the
window.
Now you can start the registration
process. Keep in mind that each of the
following steps has to be completed
within 30 seconds or less.
Touch the engine start button with your
registered smart key. You should hear
one beep. Remove the registered key from
the car and then place the new key into
the vehicle.
Touch the engine start button with your
new smart key.
After you hear a beep sound, your new
key should be registered. verify that
you can start the car to test your new
key.
Thank you for watching. Once again,
please subscribe to my channel and check
out the links in the description.